you know how you thought you mentioned
how like you'll run into people and
you'll actually have like a little bit
of a connection with them
is do you think that
like you know how you share stuff openly
more than a lot of people i think
do you think that that is an indicator
that you're doing the right thing
um because sometimes like okay so let's
say if you're in the public
light
and people will approach you or whatever
i think sometimes they can like
misrepresent who you are they're like oh
yeah maybe like they feel like they know
you you gotta podcast all this stuff and
then when they
the things they say or or they try to
like relate to you or whatever like
they're just way off a lot of the time i
think not not necessarily yeah sometimes
it can be you know but the fact that
like a random quote-unquote random
stranger can come up to you and then you
guys can relate like on a significant
like kind of deep level or whatever just
so quickly get there that's one thing
that's fascinating i mean you could have
a moment where you're having a real
moment with somebody yeah like a moment
that makes you feel something inside of
yourself
you know uh and that's real that that to
me comes from somewhere else yeah it
always like you always struck me as
someone who's like so authentic and i
think that that that is a big indicator
that you're doing the right thing if you
can really like relate to people who you
never met before
that quickly
yeah thanks man uh yeah i i just i think
for feeling so disk it's a lot of it's
so new to me feeling connection and so
it's [ __ ] like being on a bridge that
shakes you know
i don't know what you guys call that in
you know or we usually call that a
bridge that shakes
yeah but when you say it sounds way more
technical okay it's not like people
believe it okay
um
but yeah for me a lot of that stuff is
just i'm a late
i'm a late bloomer in a lot of like kind
of i think emotional kind of ways
honestly uh
and i'm not ashamed of it or anything
like that you know um but sometimes in a
world where you want to be tougher
you know it's
it's a it feels
it feels tough to sometimes learn later
in life um
but yeah i think it's nice and sometimes
i don't know what
role god is using me for you know uh
you know and i just want to try and keep
myself the best
in the best way that i can so he can use
me for the best you know like um
and i really i really believe that you
know and i don't mean it in a way like
i'm some kind of hero anything i just
you know if i can take care of myself
well i believe and i believe this for
anybody that he that
or you are your higher power it doesn't
it could be whatever your higher power
is can't use you for good you know uh
and we need more good out there and we
need each other you know um anyway i
sound like a [ __ ] weirdo dog do i
sound like a weirdo
okay
sorry keep being you bro no man i think
i think echo is spot on it's kind of it
kind of mimics or or
reinforces what i was saying earlier i
think the reason that you're popular
right now is because you reveal yourself
because you're open and i think people
you're a real person and i think people
connect to that and and i think it's
awesome because i think it allows people
to connect to themselves so i say keep
doing what you're doing theo vaughn i
appreciate it man and i appreciate you
guys having me man i really do it's good
it's making me feel excited like i'm
doing the right thing right now bang
baby